hey if your girl if your girl if your
girl gets you tattooed on it and instead
of tattooing your name she gets your
logo tattooed
[Laughter]
what do you think do you think she's
not sure about like how it might happen
or do you think she just likes your logo
more than your name i have no [ __ ]
idea that's an interesting i don't know
so you're asking if my girl were to get
my logo instead of my name yeah
would that mean she likes i i
walk me down this path again
do you think like to me like would you
think it's like
she's like she's willing to take that
risk
but not willing to sign online right
there um
i mean i'm married so
she signed your name yeah you you oh
wait one it's kind of ghetto to get your
name tattooed that's together no offense
to anybody my wife's name's on my finger
damn so i'm ghetto all right behind my
ear continue we've already we've already
established some ghetto but continue i
go to applebee's that's kind of corny i
go to applebee's this is corny yes that
is corny [ __ ] [ __ ] wow
man that's like it's like you have to
have known nurses like you were a
freshman in canada we got married
we
win
uh we got married four years ago okay
how long you know
probably like six years
how long you had to ted
i got the tap before we got married
how long ago was it listen man [ __ ] you
isaiah rashad
[Music]
damn
wait whose name's tattooed on your
[ __ ] head taylor
who's that it's not even business it was
a weird night
wait do you have a female's name
tattooed on you who cares oh and i mean
you're calling me corny we're both corny
then
that [ __ ] that shit's close closer to
your face i could cover this [ __ ] up